how much would it cost to go back to the
future you need to put together a time
machine in their heyday DeLorean sold
for $12,000 and use one sell on eBay for
about forty thousand dollars we're going
to go with the current established
retail price buy the DeLorean Motor
Company which is fifty seven thousand
five hundred dollars but what about
gasoline the car must go 88 miles per
hour to activate the flux capacitor the
DeLorean fuel tanks hold 13 gallons so
we'll assign a cost of $50 for a full
tank DeLorean car fifty seven thousand
five hundred fifty dollars the flux
capacitor is what makes time travel
possible according to scientists the
flux capacitor must be a device that can
open up wormholes or black holes similar
to a massively powerful particle
accelerator in real life one of the most
powerful particle accelerators is the
Large Hadron Collider in Switzerland it
cost the European organisation of
nuclear research nine billion dollars
for studying subatomic particles but we
can shave down that price because it
only needs to be big enough for a car
pluck'd capacitor five billion dollars
to activate the flux capacitor you need
1.21 gigawatts of energy to generate
that kind of energy you'll need
plutonium online science blog state that
five thousand six hundred dollars per
gram is a common price plutonium sixty
seven thousand three hundred dollars
once you've traveled the space-time
continuum you'll see some pretty cool
stuff but the coolest thing you'll want
to buy is a hoverboard real-life
hoverboards are in development by a
company named Hendo the Hendo board uses
four powerful magnetic engines to create
a magnetic field for levitation certain
customers were able to acquire a
hoverboard by donating $10,000 to hend
o--'s funding hoverboard ten thousand
dollars and finally you've gone back in
time and accidentally met your mother
except she won't stop trying to hook up
with you what's the price for that well
a good therapist costs about 300 an hour
a year of Oedipus complex psychotherapy
$15,600 add everything up and we get a
grand total of five billion 150 thousand
four hundred fifty dollars whoa heavy
you